ده فضى الحرس الثوري الايراني ضربت
صاروخيه وغارات بطائره مسيره ضد مقرت
تابعه لاحزاب ايرانيه معارضه داخل اقليمي
كردستان العراق وقال بيان باسم الحرس
الثوري ان ضرباته الحقد اضرارا كبيره بمن
سماهم الارهابيين التابعين للاستكبار
العالمي في كردستان العراق من جهتها اوضحت
وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ان اربعه صواريخ
سقطت فجر اليوم على مقر الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستانيه الايراني في محافظتي اربيل
وذلك بالتزامن مع تعرض مقر حزبي ومنى قرب
سليمانيه لها جماعه بطائرات مسيره مفخخه
وقال العميد علي بدوي نائب القائد العام
للحرس الثوري الايراني قال ان ايران حذرت
الحكومه العراقيه وحكومه اقليم كردستان
العراق من انها ستستهدف مقرات من سماهم
باعداء الثوره من ما دامت داخل الاراضي
العراقيه وتستهدف الشعب الايراني واضاف
انه على العراق اخراج تلك المجموعات من
اراضيها وانا ايران لن تستهدف سيادتك
ووحده الاراضي العراقيه وانما مقرت تلك
المجموعات المسلحه
واشنطن وتل ابيب بدعم هذه المجموعات
والتامر على بلاده واوضح ان القوات
الايرانيه تقوم بالرصد الاستخباراتى
وتحديد اماكن المسلحين قبل اي عمليه حتى
لا تستهدف المدنيين
ودخل متحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني حكومه بغداد واربيل الى تحملي
مسؤولياتهما تجاه ما سماه حق ايران في
ضمان امها على الحدود مع العراق وقال
كنعاني انه يتعين على اربيل الا تسمح
للجماعات الانفصاليه بتصدير السلاح الى
مديريه الشهب
والارهابيين داخل ايران لزعزعه استقرارها
حسبتها
اما وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه فاعرضت عن
رفضها رفضا قاطعا
للقصف الايراني بطائره مسيره والصواريخ
على اقليم كردستان واكدت الوزاره ان
الهجمات المتكرره التي تنفذها القوه
الايرانيه والتركيه بالصواريخ وطائره
مسيره على اقليم كردستان تعد خرقا لسياده
العراق